hi I'm Diane Muzo - mom of a
nine-year-old boy and I left him at home
to see guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and
I had such a good time here's my bottom
line positive themes this gets a 5 this
movie is all about the importance of
family whether it's the one you're born
into or the one you create friendship
sacrifice loving one another even if you
don't always show it there's a lot to
relate to here I'm not crying you're
crying violence and scare factor this
gets a for yondu's baddies the Ravagers
have some pretty scary makeup and
there's a lot of fight scenes almost
like a Tarantino movie - the gore the
bodies pile up via lasers explosions
death by outer space and the effects are
pretty creepy like not in a bloody way
but definitely not for kids who are
prone to nightmare sex and romance just
gets its - now there is a great Sam and
Diane chemistry between star-lord and
Gomorrah and their romantic tension
grows in this movie there are also some
implied sexual references plus some sexy
Android ladies but nothing graphic bad
language descriptive - there's an S word
and some a word I just like say have to
participate hordes drinking drugs and
smoking zero the guardians of the galaxy
are back and they must have each other's
backs to save the universe again from
certain doom and this story star-lord is
introduced to his father Kurt Russell
Gamora and nebula explore their sibling
rivalry and Drax Groot and Rocket
provide the comedic relief and some of
the best moments of the film it's
jam-packed with nostalgic references to
80s pop culture music TV and film
if pac-man Knight Rider and Cheers
resonate with you you are going to love
this film maybe even more than the first
one what makes this movie stand out to
me from all the superhero movies out
there are the characters relationships
now they may be aliens but they're the
way they give each other [ __ ] and are
sarcastic they feel very real and it's
totally enjoyable plus the music in the
film like the first one it's a whole
other character here which is really
enjoyable there's so much to love about
this movie it is a rip-roaring good
and would make for an excellent date
night this is rated pg-13 and I wouldn't
take my son to see this he saw the first
one reluctantly but the second is a
little darker in tone and has some
serious moments so it's not for him just
yet older tweens teens adults they will
all love this movie it is so fun I'm
Diane risotto that's your mom's move me
that's your mom's movie minute I'm Diane
risotto thanks for watching leave us a
comment below and we will see you next
time baby Groot oh my God he's so cute
it's like it's like it's like a toddler
running around in outer space